I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hey everyone, it's Jenna Fisher. Hi, I'm Angela Kinsey.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作独家的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好，我是珍娜·费舍。嗨，我是安吉拉·金斯利。
We have a great episode. It's The Alliance. It's so good. I was tickled. Can I tell you? I was tickled watching this. Same. And I made my note cards, Jenna.
我们有一集非常棒的节目。那是《同盟》。太棒了。我被逗乐了。我能告诉你吗？我看这一集时被逗乐了。我也是。而且我做了记事卡，珍娜。
I'm real excited about it. There are so many inside jokes from this episode for The Office gang. We will get to that. Angela, I'm sorry. I think we have no time for chit chat this morning. We have no time. No, we have no time because this episode is too good. There's too much to talk about.
我对此感到非常兴奋。对于《办公室》的一帮人来说，这一集里有太多的内部笑话。我们会讲到那一点的。安吉拉，对不起。我想今天早上我们没时间闲聊了。我们没时间了。不，我们没时间了，因为这一集太棒了。有太多话要说了。
But Jenna, I love chit chat. I know. Well, you're going to have to save it. Well, I have really good day two here for the ladies out there listening. I got a blow dry last night. This is what I said. We don't have time for it. This is literally what I just said.
但是珍娜，我喜欢闲聊。我知道。好吧，你得把这省省了。好吧，我这里有个给听节目的女士们的好消息，关于第二天造型的。我昨晚吹了头发。这就是我说的。我们没时间聊这个。这简直就是我刚刚说的话。
We don't have time for it. I can't tell you how great my hair looks today and I didn't even brush it. I mean, the back of it's a hot mess, but that's kind of my go-to. You are so proud of your hair that you had to get it in there even though I said we didn't have time. All right, Jenna. Get to your dang, fast facts. All right.
我们没时间聊这个。我无法形容我今天的头发有多棒，而且我甚至都没梳它。我是说，脑后勺简直是一团糟，但这基本上是我的拿手发型。你对自己的头发太骄傲了，以至于我明明说没时间，你还是非要把它塞进去。好吧，珍娜。快说你那要命的快讯吧。好吧。
The Alliance, season one, episode four. I'm listening. This is written by Mike Schurr and directed by Brian Gordon. A little bit of trivia, Mike Schurr plays Moe's on our show. He does. He plays Moe's. Not yet. Not yet.
《同盟》，第一季，第四集。我听着呢。这一集由迈克·舒尔编剧，布莱恩·戈登执导。一点小八卦，迈克·舒尔在我们的剧里扮演摩斯。他确实演了。他演了摩斯。还不是。还不是。
And he's also just insanely talented. I mean, you know, look him up on IMDb. He's writing everywhere. He's everywhere. Yeah. He produces a million amazing television shows. If you're watching a television show and you love it, Mike Schurr probably made it. Mike Schurr's probably doing it.
而且他简直聪明绝顶。我是说，你知道的，在 IMDb 上查查他。他到处都在编剧。他无处不在。对。他制作了数百万部精彩的电视剧。如果你在看一部电视剧而且很喜欢，那可能就是迈克·舒尔制作的。迈克·舒尔可能正在做这个。
Yes. So I'm going to start with a synopsis on this episode. I know we usually start with our fast facts. Oh my God. What are you going rogue? What's going rogue? I'm going rogue. What are you using to allow any chit chat?
是的。所以我要从这一集的剧情简介开始。我知道我们通常以快讯开始。天哪。你要特立独行吗？什么叫特立独行？我要特立独行了。你用什么来允许任何闲聊的？
I'm starting with a synopsis. You're like in a black shirt with a black hoodie. You've got camel pants. I know. What's happening? Are you taking a kickboxing class or something? You know, I took my kickboxing yesterday. I know.
我要从剧情简介开始。你就像是穿着一件黑色衬衫配黑色连帽衫。你还穿着卡其裤。我知道。发生什么事了？你去上跆拳道课了吗？你知道的，我昨天去上跆拳道了。我知道。
I know. You're feeling very tough. I know. You're very tough. Okay. All right. Synopsis. So this episode has two basic storylines.
我知道。你觉得自己非常坚强。我知道。你非常坚强。好吧。好吧。剧情简介。所以这一集有两个基本的故事线。
One, in an attempt to raise morale, Michael insists on throwing a birthday party, even though it's no one's birthday. It's no one's birthday. The closest birthday is Meredith, so it's next month, but he insists on throwing her birthday party. And then at the same time, Jim and Dwight form an alliance. Dwight is worried about the rumored downsizing, and so he goes to Jim and suggests they form an alliance.
第一，为了提振士气，迈克尔坚持要办一个生日派对，尽管根本不是任何人的生日。根本不是任何人的生日。最近的生日是梅雷迪思的，所以是在下个月，但他坚持要为她办生日派对。与此同时，吉姆和德怀特结成了同盟。德怀特担心传闻中的裁员，于是他去找吉姆，建议他们结成同盟。
And this is like candy for Jim. He's like, oh my God. Yes. Oh my God. This is such a great opportunity to mess with Dwight. Both of these themes are because people are afraid that the office is being downsized. This is a big theme of the first season of the office. And so Michael thinks the answer is to throw a party, and Dwight thinks the answer is to
这简直对吉姆来说就像糖果一样。他觉得，哦，天哪。太好了。哦，天哪。这真是一个捉弄德怀特的绝佳机会。这两个主题都是因为大家担心办公室会被裁员。这是《办公室》第一季的一个大主题。所以迈克尔认为解决方法是开个派对，而德怀特认为解决方法是
form an alliance and spy on his co-workers. Yes. You know, it's not Meredith's birthday, right? But we sort of forced this party, but it is Ryan the Timp's birthday. Oh yes. That's a little nugget at the end of the episode. It's such a great reveal at the end. Okay.
结成同盟并监视他的同事。是的。你知道的，这根本不是梅雷迪思的生日，对吧？但我们有点强行办了这个派对，不过这确实是临时演员瑞安的生日。哦，是的。那是这一集结尾的一个小彩蛋。结尾揭晓得太棒了。好吧。
I didn't mean to jump ahead. Okay. That's all right. Well, I'm going to give a little fast fact. So fast facts for anyone who's new to listening. These are just a few fun facts about an episode that sort of are overreaching. They apply to the whole episode rather than just one scene. And for those of you just tuning in, Jenna came up with the idea of fast facts.
我不是故意抢先剧透的。好吧。没关系。好吧，我要提供一个简短的快讯。对于任何新听众来说的快讯。这些只是一些关于一集的趣事，它们比较宏观。它们适用于整集，而不仅仅是一个场景。而对于那些刚刚调到这里的听众，快讯这个主意是珍娜想出来的。
That's right. And she really loves it. And I call her keeper of the notes. She is keeper of the notes, keeper of the records. She loves a list. Angela. Yes. She loves a list.
没错。而且她真的很喜欢这个。我叫她是笔记守护者。她是笔记守护者，记录守护者。她喜欢列清单。安吉拉。是的。她喜欢列清单。
Anyone who has been listening regularly knows these two things. Oh, Jenna just cut some eyes at me. I'm telling you. She is sassy today. And now we also know you have good hair today. Okay. The first fast fact is that this episode was inspired by the television show, Survivor. Yes.
任何经常收听的人都知道这两件事。哦，珍娜刚刚冲我翻了个白眼。我跟你说。她今天很有个性。现在我们也知道了你今天头发很好。好吧。第一个快讯是，这一集的灵感来自电视剧《幸存者》。是的。
Yes. The writing staff watched a bunch of episodes of Survivor and they did this so that they could properly satirize the way people talk about alliances and this idea of, you know, ganging up against other people. And also though you have to mention that our cameraman, Randall Einhorn and Matt Stone, their background was Survivor. Yes. They were camera operators on Survivor, which for me as a huge Survivor fan.
是的。《幸存者》的编剧团队看了很多集《幸存者》，他们这样做是为了能够恰当地讽刺人们谈论同盟的方式，以及这种，你知道的，抱团对抗其他人的想法。不过你也得提到我们的摄影师兰德尔·艾因霍恩和马特·石，他们的背景就是《幸存者》。是的。他们是《幸存者》的摄像操作员，对我这个《幸存者》的超级粉丝来说。
You're a huge Survivor fan. You guys, Jeff Probst, officiated my wedding. Now, this is something that, you know, now here's the thing. If you know Jenna and she's like from St. Louis, she's a good Midwest gal. And I remember when you were planning your wedding and you're like, Jeff Probst is going to officiate. And you're like, the guy from Survivor, what is happening? So here's what happened.
你是个超级粉丝。你们大家，杰夫·普罗斯特，主持了我的婚礼。现在，这是一件，你知道的，这里有个情况。如果你了解珍娜，她来自圣路易斯，她是个优秀的美国中西部女孩。我记得当你在筹备婚礼时，你说杰夫·普罗斯特要来主持。而你说，那个《幸存者》里的家伙，这到底是怎么回事？所以事情是这样的。
My now husband, Lee and I, we were at an Emmys party. Now I know out there, people think that when you go to these parties, you become friends with people, but you really don't. Like you kind of hobnob, you maybe take a picture and then you never see them again. And you sort of stick with the people you already knew. Oh my gosh. I just would always sit like next to like Brian and Oscar and you. Yes.
我和我现在的丈夫李，我们在一个艾美奖派对上。现在我知道在外面，人们以为当你们去这些派对时，你们会和大家成为朋友，但实际上你们并没有。就像你只是社交一番，可能拍张照片，然后就再也见不到他们了。而且你通常只和那些你本来就认识的人待在一起。哦，天哪。我总是坐在比如布莱恩、奥斯卡和你旁边。是的。
You know, I'd like to go meet people. You're better at it. I think you're better at it. Am I? Yes. Remember when you made me go up to Meryl Streep? That's a story for later. Yeah.
你知道的，我喜欢去结识新朋友。你更擅长这个。我觉得你更擅长。是吗？是的。还记得你逼着我去找梅丽尔·斯特里普的时候吗？那是后话了。是的。
And Amy Adams and I, I, I said nothing. I look like such a dork. I just walked up and was like, we had to meet Meryl Streep. I'm sorry. If you have a chance to meet Meryl Streep, you don't let that go. Well, anyway, that's a great story, but we'll save it. Okay. Okay.
还有安妮·海瑟薇和...我，我，我什么都没说。我看起来像个白痴。我径直走过去说，我们必须去见梅丽尔·斯特里普。抱歉。如果你有机会见到梅丽尔·斯特里普，你绝不会放过。好吧，不管怎样，这是个好故事，但我们先留着。好吧。好吧。
Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. So I ended up approaching Jeff Probst at this party. See, you would approach Jeff Probst. I would never go up to him. Okay. Go on.
说吧。说吧。说吧。所以最后我在派对上走近了杰夫·普罗斯特。你看，你会走近杰夫·普罗斯特。我绝对不会走过去。好吧。继续。
And I told him that I was a huge survivor fan and I was. And we ended up really hitting it off, especially Jeff and my then-fiancé, Lee, really hit it off because they had tennis in common. They played tennis together. Oh, they were tennis pals. Yeah. So after this party, they ended up becoming tennis pals. And then we started going to dinners, couples dinners, you know, Jeff's wife is so lovely.
我告诉他我是《幸存者》的超级粉丝，我确实是。最后我们真的非常合得来，尤其是杰夫和我当时的未婚夫李，他们真的很合得来，因为他们有共同的爱好——网球。他们一起打网球。哦，他们是网球伙伴。是的。所以在派对之后，他们最终成了网球伙伴。然后我们开始一起吃晚餐，情侣晚餐，你知道的，杰夫的妻子非常可爱。
Her name is Lisa. So we just ended up becoming great friends with them. And at one of our dinners, Jeff said that he was nervous because that upcoming weekend, he was going to be officiating a friend's wedding. And you were like, ding, ding, ding, ding. Jeff Probst is the type of guy where he is really caring and he has a sort of just like a spiritual soul kind of like Rainn Wilson, right? Yes.
她叫丽莎。所以我们最终和他们成了很好的朋友。在我们的其中一次晚餐上，杰夫说他很紧张，因为接下来的那个周末，他要去为朋友的婚礼担任证婚人。而你当时就觉得，叮，叮，叮，叮。杰夫·普罗斯特就是那种非常体贴的人，他有一种类似于雷恩·威尔逊的那种精神灵魂，对吧？是的。
I'll tell you one thing. When you talk to someone like Jeff or Rainn, you feel like you're the only person in the room. Yes. And they're truly interested in you. They really want to know you. They care about what you care about. Like they're interested in you.
我告诉你一件事。当你和像杰夫或雷恩这样的人交谈时，你会觉得自己是房间里唯一的人。是的。而且他们是真心对你感兴趣。他们真的很想了解你。他们在乎你在乎的事。就像他们对你很感兴趣。
And I thought that's the kind of person you want to officiate your wedding. You want that kind of soulful, caring person. But then also he's a host, so he's comfortable sort of commanding attention from a group of people. Wow. And it was awesome. You were there, Angela. It was awesome.
我想这就是你想找来为你的婚礼证婚的那种人。你需要那种有灵魂、体贴的人。但同时他也是个主持人，所以他很擅长掌控一群人的注意力。哇。而且太棒了。你也在场，安吉拉。太棒了。
I was there. Here's my one story from your wedding. Jeff Probst, before your wedding, called me. He got my phone number from you and was like, can you tell me any stories about Jenna that you know from the years? And I was supposed to give a speech at your wedding, a toast. I was going to give a toast. You had asked me to give a toast.
我在场。这是我关于你婚礼的唯一故事。杰夫·普罗斯特，在你的婚礼前，打电话给我。他从你那里得到了我的电话号码，然后说：“你能告诉我任何你多年来所知道的关于珍娜的故事吗？”我本来应该在你的婚礼上发表演讲，说几句祝酒词。我打算说祝酒词。你邀请我做祝酒词的。
And I sort of told Jeff some of my stories about you that I was going to have in my toast. Oh, no. And he stole them. He took some of my bits. And so then, like when I got up to give my toast, I don't know if you remember, I'm like, I'm going to say a few things. I mean, Jeff Probst pretty much stole all my stuff, but whatever. And I called him out for stealing my bits.
然后我把一些我打算在祝酒词里讲的关于你的故事告诉了杰夫。哦，不。他把它们偷走了。他拿走了一些我的梗。所以然后，就像我起立致祝酒词时，我不知道你记不记得，我说：“我要说几件事情。我是说，杰夫·普罗斯特几乎偷了我所有的东西，但管他呢。”我当场揭发他偷了我的梗。
So as you were watching the wedding, all you were thinking was like he kept stealing your stuff. Yes. Dang it. Probstie. I told you and I called him Probstie. I made up a nickname for him. I'm sure he loved it.
所以当你看着婚礼时，你脑子里想的全部都是他一直在偷你的东西。是的。可恶。普罗斯蒂。我告诉你了，我叫他普罗斯蒂。我给他起了一个昵称。我确信他一定很喜欢。
All right. Next, fast fact. What? The original cut of this episode came in at 40 minutes, which is way too long because for a show to air on television, on network TV, on network TV, it can only be 20 minutes and 30 seconds. Well, that's crazy room for the commercials. Hey, network TV people, I just have a little tip for you.
好的。下一个快讯。什么？这一集的最初剪辑版长达40分钟，这实在太长了，因为一档要在电视上播出的节目，在电视网上，在电视网上，它只能有20分30秒。好吧，这给广告留出了疯狂的空间。嘿，电视网的人们，我刚好有一个小建议给你们。
And I know you want me, you know, to weigh in on things, change up your format. I know because they had to cut out like half of what they wanted to cut. And Greg considered splitting this into two episodes. I wish they could take all the stuff they cut out and re-release it all. Wouldn't that be so fun? I will tell you, on the season one DVD, they have the deleted scenes from this episode and they are delightful. I watched them and most of what was cut out were really funny kind of general office life
而且我知道你们希望我，你知道的，对事情发表意见，改变你们的节目形式。我知道，因为他们不得不剪掉他们想要剪掉的一半左右。格雷格甚至考虑把这一集拆成两集。我真希望他们能把自己剪掉的所有东西都拿出来重新发行。那不是很有趣吗？我告诉你，在第一季的DVD上，他们有这一集的删减片段，它们太棒了。我看过，大部分被剪掉的都是非常有趣的、关于办公室普通生活
scenes. So there was this great bit between Jim and Dwight where Dwight is changing his password where he's going on and on about how his password on his computer is the best and Jim keeps guessing it. He's like, is it Frodo? And it is. And it is. And then there's another really great one of Dwight just cleaning out the fridge in
的场景。所以吉姆和德怀特之间有一个很棒的片段，德怀特在改密码，他喋喋不休地说他在电脑上的密码是最好的，而吉姆一直在猜。他说，是弗罗多吗？结果还真是。结果还真是。然后还有另一个非常棒的片段，是德怀特在清理休息室的冰箱，他把吉姆的金枪鱼三明治给扔了。还有一个非常棒的场景，当我看到这个删减片段时，我想起了当时拍摄的情景，迈克尔指导帕姆如何面带微笑地接电话，简直太有趣了。哦，天哪。
the break room and he throws away Jim's tuna sandwich. There was also a really great scene that when I was watching this deleted scene, I remembered shooting and it was so funny of Michael coaching Pam on how to answer the phone with a smile. Oh my Lord. He said that she sounded really gloomy. And he then stands by her desk and waits for the phone to ring and there's just these long pauses. Awkward pauses.
他说她听起来真的很忧郁。然后他站在她的办公桌旁，等着电话铃响，中间有很长的停顿。尴尬的停顿。
And then he does this funny thing where he puts his hands in front of his face and he says, tell me if I'm smiling or not. Oh my Lord. He's like, Dunder Mifflin, this is Michael. And she's like, yes, you're smiling. And then he's like, Dunder Mifflin, this is Michael. And I'm like, not smiling and he's like, you hear the difference. And then I have this line where I'm like, that was a really great example.
然后他做了一个有趣的动作，把手放在脸前说：“告诉我我是不是在笑。”哦，天哪。他说：“丹德米夫林，我是迈克尔。”而她说：“是的，你在笑。”然后他说：“丹德米夫林，我是迈克尔。”而我说：“没笑。”然后他说：“你听出区别了吗？”然后我有一句台词是：“那真是一个很好的例子。”
Thank you. But so there is a place, if you're interested, the season one DVD has all of these deleted scenes on it. And you know, by the way, the reason Greg couldn't split this up into two episodes, he thought of doing one episode that was just about throwing the birthday party and one episode that was just about the alliance, the big prank. And then you could have filled it out with some of these general office life scenes. The problem was at the end of the episode, we all have birthday hats.
谢谢。不过，如果你感兴趣的话，第一季的DVD上收录了所有这些删减片段。顺便告诉你们，格雷格不能把这一集拆成两集的真正原因，是他曾考虑过制作一集只讲办生日派对，另一集只讲同盟关系、那个大恶作剧。然后你就可以用这些普通的办公室生活场景来充实内容。问题是在这一集的结尾，我们都戴着生日帽。
We all have cake and birthday hats. And so the end of the alliance part ends with birthday hats. And so he couldn't do it. Jenna, I have some trivia on my note cards, but you need to tell me when you're done with your fast facts. So I have one more fact. I don't want to mess up your list. I see.
我们都有蛋糕和生日帽。所以同盟部分的结尾以生日帽告终。因此他没能这么做。珍娜，我的记事卡上有一些琐事，但你需要告诉我你什么时候讲完快讯。我还有一个事实。我不想打乱你的清单。我懂。
Don't look at my note cards. I can see one of my fast facts on your note cards. Stop looking at my homework. Well, my goodness. Well, excuse me. Here's my last fast fact. Okay, do it. Near and dear to my heart and yours.
别看我的记事卡。我能看到你记事卡上有一个我的快讯。别看我的家庭作业。好吧，天哪。好吧，打扰了。这是我的最后一个快讯。好吧，说吧。
This is the first time we meet the party planning committee. The PPC. The PPC. Oh, my gosh. Just years of just lovely memories of us planning ridiculous parties. Oh, my gosh. I remember that because I remember that there was just a tiny bit that was scripted. And then Greg told us, Greg Daniels said, guys, just keep planning the party.
这离我的心和你的心都很近。这是我们第一次见到派对策划委员会。PPC。PPC。哦，天哪。多年来，我们策划那些荒谬派对的美好回忆。哦，天哪。我记得那是因为我记得当时只有一点点是写好的剧本。然后格雷格告诉我们，格雷格·丹尼尔斯说：“伙计们，继续策划派对。”
Yeah, just we're going to record you. And that's when Phyllis was naming colors, like what color streamers. And then we did this whole, like we did a whole other tangent about, do we say happy birthday or do we say surprise? Or do we say happy birthday surprise? Well, who would say happy birthday surprise? Who would say that? You're right.
是的，我们这就把你们录下来。也就是在那时，菲莉丝在说颜色，比如彩带用什么颜色。然后我们做了一整套，就像我们讨论了另一个题外话，我们是说“生日快乐”还是说“惊喜”？或者我们说“生日快乐惊喜”？好吧，谁会说“生日快乐惊喜”？谁会这么说？你是对的。
We should start with surprise. You say surprise first. And then Pam's just caught in the middle of you and Phyllis. And I love the dynamic of your subtle bullying of Phyllis. Yes. Your famous line, I think green is kind of horish, is in this episode. Yes. And Phyllis is, of course, wearing green.
我们应该从“惊喜”开始。你先说“惊喜”。然后帕姆就被夹在你和菲莉丝中间。我喜欢你对菲莉丝那种潜移默化的霸凌的动态。是的。你那句名言“我觉得绿色有点像妓女穿的”，就在这一集里。是的。而菲莉丝当然穿着绿色。
And then I throw her under the bus at the end. I blame her for the lame streamers, the red streamers. I just love all of it. And there was so much that was there that got cut. And I know why. I mean, no one wants to watch like 20 minutes of us trying to plan a party, but it was so fun. You, I always, I felt like there could be a spinoff, like a web, a web series called
然后我在最后把她推下车。我把那些逊毙了的彩带，红色彩带归咎于她。我简直爱极了这一切。有太多东西被剪掉了。我知道为什么。我是说，没人想看我们花20分钟试图策划一个派对，但这真的太有趣了。你，我总是，我觉得可以有一个衍生剧，比如网络剧，叫做
the party planning committee. The PPC. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Or they like uncovered all of the, the like unused footage of us planning parties. Oh my God. That's got to exist in a vault somewhere. Somewhere.
派对策划委员会。PPC。是的。哦，天哪。或者他们挖掘了所有我们策划派对时未使用的素材。哦，天哪。那一定存在某个地方的保险库里。某个地方。
I would totally want to see it. But we did. We had so much fun. And we, we took such long pauses and it was so boring. It was so boring. And Pam was dying inside. My take on that scene was that I should speak very little. Like how I got roped into being on this committee, I feel like I was forced onto it by Michael.
我绝对想看。但我们确实这么做了。我们玩得很开心。而且我们，我们停顿了很长时间，真的很无聊。真的很无聊。帕姆内心都快死掉了。我对那个场景的理解是我应该少说话。比如我是怎么被拉进这个委员会的，我觉得我是被迈克尔强行塞进来的。
I don't think I volunteered. And I just wanted the meeting to be over and it didn't, you know, but you have that. Have you been in those office? Oh my God. Yes. I, I mean, come on. You and I both tipped and we worked in offices and I mean, yes, you've been in those meetings where it's that, that famous like line that people say like this whole meeting could have
我不认为我是自愿的。我只是想让会议快点结束，但并没有，你知道的，但你有那种经历。你经历过那些办公室里的...哦，天哪。是的。我是说，拜托。你我都打过工，也在办公室工作过，我是说，是的，你经历过那些会议，就是那种人们常说的名言，整场会议本来可以用一封邮件解决。是的。就是那样。
been one email. Yeah. That's, that's what it is. Um, you know, I have to point out my hairstyle in this party planning committee scene because that hairstyle was bonkers crazy. It was like, I don't know, we took two pieces and we twisted it back to the back of my head and then we did a low ponytail that connected it and I had so many like rubber bands and pins holding it.
嗯，我必须指出我在这个派对策划委员会场景中的发型，因为那个发型简直疯狂得像个疯子。就像是，我不知道，我们拿了两股头发把它扭到脑后，然后做了一个连接它的低马尾，我用了好多皮筋和发夹固定。
And then I had one piece that kept flopping out and it drove me crazy. And by the end of the episode, I was like, I don't ever want this. I can't do this again. I can't have this hairstyle again. You can do whatever you want. But this weird multiple like rubber band, I can't do it again. Angela, I feel like we've come full circle here. We started by speaking about your hair and now we're speaking about your hair again.
然后有一股头发一直散落下来，把我快逼疯了。到了这一集结束时，我想，我再也不要这样了。我不能再这样了。我再也不能弄这种发型了。你想怎么样都行。但这个奇怪的多个皮筋发型，我不能再来了。安吉拉，我觉得我们这里转了一个满圈。我们从讨论你的头发开始，现在我们又在讨论你的头发。
It's almost like, it's almost perfect. This must make you so happy, Jenna. It does. And I take it back. I think that you were right to have that banter. I will take that, Jenna Fisher. Let's take a break and then we'll come back and we'll start to really dive into this episode. Okay.
这简直就像，几乎完美。这一定让你很高兴，珍娜。确实如此。我收回刚才的话。我觉得你刚才进行那些插科打诨是对的。我接受了，珍娜·费舍。让我们休息一下，然后回来开始真正深入探讨这一集。好吧。
Scene by scene. Oh, let's do it. Well, welcome back. Welcome back. We're talking about the Alliance. Let's get into it, Jenna. All right. The very first scene in this episode is Dwight waiting outside of the bathroom to confront
一个场景接一个场景地剖析。哦，我们开始吧。欢迎回来。欢迎回来。我们在谈论《同盟》。我们深入探讨吧，珍娜。好的。这一集的第一个场景是德怀特在浴室外面等着质问
Michael about the downsizing rumors. And I just have to say, we do this a lot to Michael and it always makes me laugh. First of all, how much time does he spend in the bathroom? And whenever people want to talk to them, they, because this already happened, Oscar Yes. waits outside the bathroom to confront him. Yes. We're always bombarding him outside of the restroom.
迈克尔关于裁员的传闻。我不得不说，我们对迈克尔经常这样做，而且总是把我逗笑。首先，他在浴室里待多长时间？每当人们想跟他们谈话时，因为这已经发生过了，奥斯卡，是的，在浴室外面等着质问他。是的。我们总是在洗手间外面围攻他。
Well, I think, I think it's because Michael is always avoiding us. He's like, he always is avoiding work, right? Yes. Unless he has a joke to tell or unless he has good news. Yes. Otherwise he hides. And so people wait for him outside of the bathroom and he's always startled. I have a lot of empathy for him because as a mother, I feel like every time I go to the
嗯，我想，我想这是因为迈克尔总是在躲避我们。他总是，总是逃避工作，对吧？是的。除非他有笑话要讲，或者有好消息要宣布。是的。否则他就藏起来。所以人们在浴室外面等他，而他总是吓一大跳。我对他很有同情心，因为作为母亲，我觉得每次我去
bathroom, someone is literally waiting outside the door for me. Always. Always. I don't understand it. What is that? I don't know. Why can't mothers go to the bathroom without someone outside the door? I don't know.
洗手间时，总有人 literalmente（字面意思）在门外等我。总是。总是。我不明白。这是为什么？我不知道。为什么妈妈们上个厕所外面都得有人？我不知道。
You know, I have such like empathy for my parents now in a different way. I remember my dad going to the bathroom one time and I was outside the door like, and I think I was like messing with the door. I was like doing like click, click, click, click on the door and click, click, click. And my dad was like, I'm just trying to go to the bathroom. And I was like, hey, dad, he's like, he just needed five minutes. Just five minutes. Five minutes.
你知道的，我现在以一种不同的方式对我的父母产生了强烈的同情心。我记得有一次我爸爸去上厕所，我在门外，就像是，我想我当时在搞门。我一直在门上做咔哒、咔哒、咔哒、咔哒的动作，咔哒、咔哒。我爸爸就说：“我只是想上个厕所。”而我说：“嘿，爸爸。”他说，他只需要五分钟。只要五分钟。五分钟。
My kids slide things under the door. Always. Slide things under the door. Like that drawing couldn't wait. No. Or they just open the door. Or they just come on in. I know.
我的孩子们会把东西从门缝底下塞进来。总是。从门缝底下塞东西。就好像那幅画不能等一样。不。或者他们直接把门打开。或者他们直接闯进来。我知道。
I know. Okay. Sorry. Okay. Anyway, poor Michael is accosted as he comes out of the bathroom once again. I have like a fun little Dwight thing that I noticed in rewatching this. What? So it is such a joy for me to go back and rewatch these episodes.
我知道。好吧，抱歉。好吧。不管怎样，可怜的迈克尔再次在走出浴室时遭到纠缠。我重看这一集时注意到一个有趣的小德怀特细节。什么？重看这些对我来说真是一种享受。
I know you're having a lot of fun with it too, but I always thought the first bobble head that Dwight ever had was the one that my character gave him for Valentine's. Really? Of himself. I knew that wasn't true. What? The reason your character made him a bobble head of himself was because of his love of bobble heads.
我知道你也很享受，但我一直以为德怀特拥有的第一个摇头娃娃是我这个角色在情人节送他的那个。真的吗？他自己的。我知道那不是真的。什么？你这个角色给他定制了一个他自己的摇头娃娃，是因为他热爱摇头娃娃。
It's just maybe something you want to look into for your character, Anne. What? Really? Yes. That's- Was it a known thing that Dwight loved bobble heads? Yes. Did he have-
这也许是你想要为你的角色安妮调查一下的事情。什么？真的吗？是的。那是——德怀特喜欢摇头娃娃是众所周知的事情吗？是的。他有——
He has them on his desk. Oh my God. Wow. How did I miss that? I mean- Jenna is now looking at me like I'm having, like I might need to take medication for something. Oh my God. That card.
他的桌子上摆着呢。哦，天哪。哇。我怎么会错过这个？我是说——珍娜现在看着我的眼神，就像我可能需要吃点药什么的。哦,天哪。那张卡片。
That just occurred to you now in the rewatch. That just occurred to me. I thought he was so excited because I gave him a bobble head. Oh my God. Oh my Lord. I am a ding bet. Okay. I wrote on my no card.
你现在重看才突然意识到这一点吗？我刚刚才意识到。我还以为他那么兴奋是因为我送了他一个摇头娃娃。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我真是一个大笨蛋。好吧。我在记事卡上写了。
You have to hear what I wrote. I'm such an idiot. Dwight has a bunch of bobble heads. Exclamation point. Baseball team. He can't- I counted six bobble heads. Are they from the Phillies?
你必须听听我写了什么。我真是个白痴。德怀特有一堆摇头娃娃。感叹号。棒球队伍。他不能——我数了数，有六个摇头娃娃。它们是费城人队的吗？
Oh my God. Yes. Because- How many times did I walk past his desk and I didn't notice that? Because he collected bobble heads. I had him- Your character makes him a bobble head of himself. That's where your character got the idea.
哦，天哪。是的。因为——我多少次从他的桌子旁走过却没有注意到这一点？因为他收集摇头娃娃。我让他——你的角色给他定制了一个他自己的摇头娃娃。这就是你角色灵感的来源。
Oh, I hit my head. It's a good thing. It's a good thing you don't write the show. I hit my head on the microphone. Oh my God. How did I miss that? I mean- So this, I think, is an example of how fans of the show might know it better than some
哦，我撞到头了。太好了。幸亏你没有写剧本。我撞到麦克风上了。哦，天哪。我怎么会漏掉这个？我是说——所以这，我认为，是一个粉丝可能比某些
of the people on it. Oh my God. As Angela is pointing out a fact of the show that landed on everyone else but her. I was so excited. Look at my no card. So many exclamation points, guys. I put so many- Six bobble heads.
演员更了解这部剧的例子。哦，天哪。当安吉拉指出一个大家都知道、唯独她不知道的剧集事实时。我当时太兴奋了。看我的记事卡。有那么多的感叹号，伙计们。我写了那么多——六个摇头娃娃。
They're all baseball players. I do have some other good no cards coming up. Let's see another no card. Okay. We'll decide. All right. Let's see what happens. I put an asterisk for this one because I thought it was so good.
它们全都是棒球运动员。我还有一些其他很好的记事卡要讲。让我们看看另一张记事卡。好吧。我们决定。好吧。看看会发生什么。我给这个打了个星号，因为我觉得太棒了。
Do you know that there is a continuity error? Aha. Oh, look at your face now, Jenna Fisher. All right. I don't have this in my note. Oh, I know. There's a continuity error. What is it?
你知道这里有一个连续性错误吗？啊哈。哦，看看你的脸，珍娜·费舍。好吧。我记事卡里没有这个。哦，我知道。有一个连续性错误。是什么？
And it's in accounting at seven minutes. At seven minutes, Michael is talking about what he's going to write on the bird day birthday card. Yes. And he says, and you know what, guys? I have set the bar really high. Oh, Sam, pull it up. Pull it up on the screen.
而且在第七分钟的会计部门。在第七分钟，迈克尔正在谈论他要在生日卡片上写什么。是的。他说：“你知道吗，伙计们？我把标准定得非常高。”哦，萨姆，把它调出来。把它调到屏幕上。
Sam is here in the booth. He's going to show Jenna. All right. I'm at the copier at the beginning of this talking head behind Michael. I'm in my beige sweater that I wear through the whole episode with my crazy ponytail. All right. And then it cuts to me at my desk during his talking head. And I'm in a white T-shirt, a white button down with a black sweater vest and a different
萨姆就在控制室里。他要给珍娜看。好吧。我在迈克尔身后的这个talking head（访谈）开始时正站在复印机旁。我穿着米色毛衣，扎着那个疯狂的马尾辫，这身打扮贯穿了整集。好吧。然后画面切到了他的talking head期间我在我办公桌前的镜头。我穿着一件白色T恤，一件白色衬衫，外面套着一件黑色毛衣背心，而且
hairstyle. They edited in a different piece of footage to cut to. And I'm completely... You're in a different outfit. Completely from a different episode. I'm in a white button down and a black sweater. I'm looking at it now. I see it.
发型也不一样。他们剪辑进了一段完全不同的素材来切换。而且我完全……你换了一套衣服。完全是来自另一集的。我穿着白色衬衫和黑色毛衣。我现在正看着呢。我看到了。
Okay. Beige sweater. Okay. Over Michael's shoulder through the window. At the copier. Jim Rowe. Meredith, I heard you're turning 46, but come on. You're an accountant.
好吧。米色毛衣。好吧。透过窗户看着迈克尔的肩膀。在复印机旁。吉姆在说：“梅雷迪思，我听说你快46岁了，但拜托。你是个会计。把数字稍微改一下就行了。”我打赌。挺搞笑的。看我在复印机旁。
Just fudge the numbers. I bet. Pretty funny. See me at the copier. I don't appreciate condoning corporate fraud, though. Now I leave the copier. I go to my desk. Go to your desk.
不过我不赞成纵容公司欺诈。现在我离开复印机。我走到我的办公桌前。走到你的办公桌前。
This is apparently when you're changing clothes. Really? So what are you doing back there? You're putting on a... We don't expect it. I've already set the bar. See? Really high.
这显然是你在换衣服的时候。真的吗？那你去后面干什么？你在穿一个……我们没有料到。我已经把标准定下来了。看到了吗？非常高。
Look at that. Look at that. I'm in a completely different outfit. Ha ha. Whoa. I have something else to talk about in this scene. But, okay. Can you just say though, okay, maybe I fumbled the bobble head moment, but I did catch
看看那个。看看那个。我换了一身完全不同的衣服。哈哈。哇。我在这场戏里还有别的事要说。不过，好吧。你能不能说，好吧，也许我在摇头娃娃的那个时刻搞砸了，但我确实抓住了一个
a continuity error. Okay. So suck it. Suck it. Okay. I'm giving that to you. I didn't see it. I didn't see it.
连续性错误。好吧。所以见鬼去吧。见鬼去吧。好吧。我承认你赢了。我没看出来。我没看出来。
Thank you. I saw something. I did it. So you saw something too. What'd you see? Well, I'm not going to take credit for this. Okay. This was from IsRoses on Twitter.
谢谢你。我发现了点东西。我找到了。所以你也发现了点东西。你发现了什么？嗯，这功劳我可不揽。好吧。这是推特上的IsRoses指出的。
Okay. IZRoses, capital IZRoses on Twitter. Okay. Okay. Mentioned that in this moment, when Michael's reading Jim's comment, Jim references that Meredith is an accountant. Yeah. What?
好吧。IZRoses，推特上大写的IZRoses。好吧。好吧。她提到在这场戏里，当迈克尔在读吉姆的评语时，吉姆提到梅雷迪思是个会计。什么？
Wait. We just watched the scene and you didn't catch that. Because I was looking at my outfit. You were looking at your outfit. I was listening to the words and I heard it too. Just a dig. That's just a dig. I heard it as well.
等等。我们刚看了这场戏，而你居然没发现。因为我在看我的衣服。你在看你的衣服。我在听台词，我也听到了。这只是一个小挖苦。这只是一个小挖苦。我也听到了。
So, you know, her question was, what's up with that? I thought there were three accounts. Why does he say, you're an accountant, just fudge the numbers. This is another continuity error. Another. So here's something that I have at home. Okay. That is an amazing thing.
所以，你知道，她的问题是，怎么回事？我以为有三个账号。为什么他说，你是个会计，随便凑合一下数字就行了。这是另一个连续性错误。又一个。所以我家里有这样东西。好吧。那是一件了不起的东西。
It's called the show Bible. Okay. Do you know what a show Bible is for a TV show? I do. Okay. You know. Yeah. Let's explain it to people.
它叫剧集圣经。好吧。你知道什么是电视剧的剧集圣经吗？我知道。好吧。你知道。是的。让我们向大家解释一下。
A show Bible is a giant document. I mean, like thousands of pages. It looks like a phone book. It looks like a phone book. And in it, it lists every character and every fact about them and every episode. If we learn something new about them, it gets put in the Bible. Yes. So it says our job.
剧集圣经是一份巨大的文件。我是说，有几千页。它看起来像一本电话簿。它看起来像一本电话簿。里面列出了每个角色、关于他们的每个事实以及每一集。如果我们了解了关于他们的什么新东西，它就会被放进圣经里。是的。所以它写明了我们的工作。
It says our relationships to people. I have a copy of the show Bible for the office. Wow. How I got this, I don't know. I mean, there's probably only like two or three of them. Yes. I know. And I think I borrowed it.
它写明了我们与人们的关系。我有一份办公室的剧集圣经复印件。哇。我是怎么弄到这东西的，我不知道。我是说，可能只有两三本吧。是的。我知道。我想我是借来的。
Jenna. Because I over the summer. And you didn't give it back? Yes. I think this is true. Over the summer from season eight to season nine, Greg Daniels came to John and I and asked us if we had any ideas for our final character arc in season nine. And he said, if it helps you, you can borrow the show Bible.
珍娜。因为我是在夏天。你没还吗？是的。我想这是真的。在第八季到第九季之间的那个夏天，格雷格·丹尼尔斯找到我和约翰，问我们对第九季中我们最终的角色弧线有什么想法。他说，如果对你们有帮助，你们可以借用剧集圣经。
So wait, Greg. Jenna has your show. I've got if you've been looking for it. Maybe I shouldn't be saying this out loud because I really love my show Bible. I could probably make a copy before I return it. I think you should make a copy. According to the show Bible, Meredith's job is customer service rep slash supplier relations. She is not an accountant.
等等，格雷格。珍娜有你的剧。如果一直在找它，那就是我拿了。也许我不该大声说出来，因为我真的很喜欢我的剧集圣经。我可能在还回去之前复印一份。我想你应该复印一份。根据剧集圣经，梅雷迪思的工作是客服代表兼供应商关系专员。她不是会计。
No, she's not an accountant. No. And is Rosas said, what is her job? Because I know she's not an accountant. So that's your answer. So Kelly is a customer service rep and I remember there was a bit of a story where we put her back in that other room in the annex back by Toby because she talked too much. She was too chatty and she was bothering Meredith.
不，她不是会计。不。IsRoses说，她的工作是什么？因为我知道她不是会计。所以这就是你的答案。凯莉是个客服代表，我记得有个情节是，我们把她调回了托比后面附属建筑的那个房间里，因为她话太多了。她太唠叨了，一直在烦梅雷迪思。
So they moved her back there. But really the reason she sat back there was because she was a writer and they didn't want her to waste her writing time doing background work. Yeah. So she had to be separated so she could get out to write. But they made it a story point. You know what Greg said one time? We had a new writer one season and he was talking to me, they were going to be giving
所以他们把她调到了后面。但实际上她坐在后面的原因是她是个编剧，他们不想让她把写作时间浪费在做背景工作上。是的。所以她必须被隔离开来，这样她才能出去写作。但他们把这编成了一个剧情。你知道格雷格有一次说过什么吗？有一季我们来了一个新编剧，他在和我说话，他们要在剧里提供
like food in the episode and they handed me like this steak or whatever. And I was like, well, my character is a vegetarian. And he was like, oh, I didn't realize that. And I was like, yeah, my character is a vegetarian. And then Greg was like standing next to me and he was like, you know what? Anything you want to know about each of their characters, just go talk to them. They know their character. They know sort of like the canon of all, they've lived every episode and they know their individual
比如食物之类的东西，他们递给我一块牛排什么的。我就说，嗯，我的角色是个素食主义者。他说，哦，我没意识到这一点。我说，对，我的角色是个素食主义者。然后格雷格站在我旁边说，你知道吗？任何你想了解的关于他们各自角色的事，直接去问他们就行了。他们了解自己的角色。他们对所有的设定都了如指掌，他们经历过每一集，他们对各自的
character story so well. I didn't know your character was a vegetarian. When do we establish that? It's established early on and then like it's throughout, throughout all the years. Like at Diwali, I was like, I guess I'll just eat non, non. Like there's like a whole thing. Oh, I'm going to look it up in the show Bible. Okay.
角色故事了解得太透彻了。我不知道你的角色是个素食主义者。我们是什么时候确立这一点的？很早就确立了，然后就一直贯穿所有这些年。比如在排灯节那集，我说，我想我只能吃馕了。这就像是一整套设定。哦，我要去剧集圣经里查一下。好吧。
Look it up in the show Bible. Maybe we should, well, let's get back to this episode a little bit. We got on a tangent. Oh, me and you on a tangent. Get out of town. Hard to believe. What are you even talking about? All right.
去剧集圣经里查一下。也许我们应该，好吧，让我们稍微回到这一集来。我们扯远了。哦，我和你扯远了。真难得。难以置信。你到底在说什么？好吧。
So there's this scene early on where Pam and Michael are stuck in the office together. And I remember I could not get through this scene. There's this never ending drum roll where Michael wants me to announce who has a birthday coming up. And he also calls you his assistant in this, which I think is hilarious. Like he has such a grandiose view of his job and who he is. You are his assistant. You're not front reception for the whole company.
所以在早期有这样一场戏，潘和迈克尔被困在办公室里。我记得我简直演不下去了。有一个没完没了的打鼓声，迈克尔想让我宣布谁快过生日了。他在剧里还叫你他的助手，我觉得这太滑稽了。就像他对自己的工作和自己的身份有着如此宏大的看法。你是他的助手。你不是整个公司的前台接待。
You're Michael's assistant. His personal assistant. You're his personal assistant. Which is not true. And he does this never ending drum roll on the desk that was making me laugh. And he wants me to announce whose birthday is coming up. And I say, there's no birthdays. And he's like, well, next one next, just who is it?
你是迈克尔的助手。他的私人助理。你是他的私人助理。这根本不是真的。他在桌子上敲着没完没了的鼓声，逗得我直笑。他想让我宣布谁的生日快到了。我说，没有人生日。然后他说，好吧，下一个，到底是谁？
So then I say, well, Meredith's birthday is next month. And then I'm just, I am just giving him nothing in the scene and he starts swooping his phone across my face to see if he can find signs of life. Yes. I cracked up. Oh my gosh. He was so funny when he was doing that. I just remember when I was rewatching this, I just remember losing it.
然后我说，好吧，梅雷迪思的生日在下个月。接着我就在戏里完全不搭理他，他开始把手机在我脸上晃来晃去，看能不能找到生命的迹象。是的。我笑崩了。哦天哪。他做那个动作时太搞笑了。我只记得当我重看这一段时，我只记得我彻底笑喷了。
But that's sort of where we set up that storyline is that we now have to throw a party for Meredith whose birthday is next month. This is like a real dork thing. But when I watch these early scenes of Michael's office, it looks so different over the years. You know, like there's that shelf in the corner. He doesn't have the tall standing shelf with two doors. It's a different lower shelf. I don't know if you like look at all that.
但这就是我们铺垫那个剧情的方式，我们现在得为梅雷迪思办个派对，她的生日在下个月。这听起来有点书呆子气。但当我看到迈克尔办公室的这些早期场景时，这些年来它看起来变化好大。你知道，就像角落里的那个架子。他没有那个带两扇门的高立柜。那是一个矮一点的柜子。我不知道你有没有注意到所有这些。
And I'm like, oh, his, like the furniture in his office keeps changing. This is a super nerdy thing for me to notice. But I mean, I don't notice bobbleheads, but if you're going to notice a major story point, if you're going to move a cabinet, I'm going to notice. So the next big sort of plot point scene is Rain asking Jim if he wants to form an alliance. And this produced one of our inside joke lines. He asks him if he wants to form an alliance and Jim pauses. And then he says, absolutely I do.
我就想，哦，他，他办公室里的家具一直在换。对我来说，注意到这一点真是个超级书呆子气的举动。不过，我是说，我没注意到摇头娃娃，但如果你要指出一个重大的剧情点，如果你要挪动一个柜子，我绝对会注意到。所以下一个重大的剧情场景是雷恩问吉姆想不想结盟。这贡献了我们的一个内部梗。他问吉姆想不想结盟，吉姆停顿了一下。然后他说，我当然想。
And we used to say that to each other on the set that used to be a thing. Absolutely I do. I love, I love this so much because it's just like Jim finally gets to have fun at work. This is like one of his favorite days you would think, right? Like, because otherwise it's just the monotony of it all and Dwight does drive him crazy. He talks about how crazy that Dwight makes him and he finally gets to like really mess with him at Dwight's invitation. That is the best.
我们以前在片场经常对彼此这么说，那成了一个梗。我当然想。我太喜欢、太喜欢这个了，因为这就像吉姆终于能在工作里找点乐子了。你可能会觉得这是他最喜欢的一天之一，对吧？因为除此之外全都是单调乏味的工作，而且德怀特确实把他快逼疯了。他谈到德怀特把他逼得有多疯，而他终于在德怀特的邀请下，可以好好整整他了。这简直太棒了。
He has that talking head where he says, sometimes it's just handed to you. I mean, you're thinking, how can I mess with this guy? And then here this wonderful gift comes. So after they decide to form the alliance, he says, don't tell anyone. You can't tell anyone. Right. Jim's like, of course not. And then Jim immediately comes up to the reception desk and tells me that he's formed
他有一段对着镜头的独白，说有时候机会就是这么从天而降。我是说，你还在想，我怎么才能整整这家伙？然后这么棒的礼物就送上门了。所以在他们决定结盟之后，他说，别告诉任何人。你不能告诉任何人。对。吉姆马上来到前台接待处，告诉我他已经和德怀特
an alliance with Dwight. And you see Dwight hovering in the background listening in and he wants to get Jim away from me. So he has this line where he's like, Jim, can I talk to you about the paper products? So I listened to the DVD commentary of this. And I guess in that scene, they have a bunch of takes where Reign, every time he would change the end of the line. And I think it was Mike Scherr said his favorite alt of that was, hey, Jim, can I talk to you
结盟了。然后你看到德怀特在背景里鬼鬼祟祟地偷听，他想把吉姆从我身边拉开。所以他有这样一句台词，他说，吉姆，我能跟你谈谈纸制品的事吗？我听了这集的DVD评论音轨。我想在那场戏里，雷恩拍了好多条，每一次他都会改变台词结尾。我想迈克·舒尔说过，他最喜欢的备用台词是，嘿，吉姆，我能跟你谈谈吗
about the, he just like mumbles that you couldn't even hear. I love that. I also loved like John, John Krasinski as Jim. Just you could just see John, I think, because we know him having so much fun. You know, like when, when they go into like the kitchen and Dwight's like, what are you doing? He's like, I'm, I'm working her. You know, like I'm on this.
关于那个，他只是嘟囔着你根本听不清。我太喜欢了。我也很喜欢约翰，约翰·卡拉辛斯基饰演的吉姆。你就能看出约翰，我觉得，因为我们了解他，他玩得太开心了。你知道的，就像当他们走进厨房，德怀特说，你在干嘛？他说，我在，我在搞定她。你知道的，就像我在处理这个。
Okay. I just saw John, like our friend John having so much fun in that moment and it just made me smile. It's so cute. The whole way that he is winding Dwight up in this episode, it happens again where he goes into the kitchen where he's supposed to be spying on Toby and Kevin who are having lunch. Oh my God.
好吧。我刚看到约翰，就像我们的朋友约翰那一刻玩得太开心了，这让我忍不住微笑。太可爱了。在这集中他逗弄德怀特的整套方式，又发生了一次，他走进厨房，本该去监视正在吃午餐的托比和凯文。哦，天哪。
That conversation is the most ridiculous, they're like amazing, boring conversation. Yes. And that produced another most frequently quoted inside joke line on the office, which is when they're talking about the bread and then John's take on that line. He says, their bread is very good, very good. We would do that all the time. And then here you are, the bread maker. Oh my gosh.
那段对话简直荒谬至极，他们的对话就像是精彩绝伦的无聊对话。是的。这也诞生了《办公室》里被引用频率最高的内部笑话台词之一，就是他们谈论面包时约翰对那句台词的处理。他说，他们的面包非常好，非常好。我们以前经常那样做。然后你就在这儿，面包大师。哦，天哪。
Full circle life moment. Guys, my bread is very good. Thank you. And we cannot not talk about the fact of how eagerly Pam is to join in Jim's prank and becomes a huge participant like in pulling this prank on Dwight. Oh yes. Yes. Well, this is their opportunity to spend time together.
完美闭环的人生时刻。伙计们，我的面包非常好。谢谢。而且我们不能不谈谈潘是多么渴望加入吉姆的恶作剧，并成为了这个针对德怀特的恶作剧的巨大参与者。哦，是的。是的。嗯，这是他们共度时光的机会。
Any opportunity to team up with Jim, I mean, in the deleted scene, we established that the phone rings very infrequently, which we could probably have guessed anyway. This is so much fun for her. She is having so much fun and Jim is just loving it. And his talking head about like how brilliant you are that you just came up, Pam came up with that all on her own. Yeah. When I come up to his desk and I'm like all fraught with it, oh, I just don't know.
任何能与吉姆组队的机会，我的意思是，在被删减的片段中，我们确定电话响得非常不频繁，其实我们大概也能猜到。这对她来说太有趣了。她玩得太开心了，吉姆也乐在其中。还有他的单人访谈，谈到你有多聪明，潘竟然能全靠自己想出那个点子。是的。当我走到他桌前，表现得十分焦虑不安，哦，我简直不知道。
Michael's told me so many things and I want to unload all these secrets, but he told me not to. And I'm doing that all so that Dwight can overhear. Yeah. Dwight's like jackpot. But Jim is just so enamored with Pam in the scene. And you know what? I'm a jam fan.
迈克尔跟我说了好多事，我想把这些秘密全倒出来，但他叫我别说。我做这一切都是为了让德怀特能听到。是的。德怀特就像中了头彩一样。但吉姆在这一幕里对潘简直迷恋得不行。你知道吗？我是杰姆（Jim和Pam）粉。
You guys. Yeah. And I love their storyline. I was just like a total fan of them. And I remember like every little nugget they had together, I was like, oh my God. And this is definitely one of those episodes. Should we take a break? I don't know.
你们。是的。我爱他们的故事线。我简直是他们的超级粉丝。我记得他们在一起的每一个小细节，我都觉得，哦，天哪。这绝对是其中一集。我们要休息一下吗？我不知道。
Do you want to take a break? Please take us to a break. Oh my God. We're back. All right. The other big part of this episode is Oscar baiting Michael into donating to his nephew's Walkathon charity. But Michael sort of not getting what a Walkathon is.
你想休息一下吗？请带我们去休息吧。哦，天哪。我们回来了。好的。这一集的另一个重头戏是奥斯卡诱使迈克尔为他侄子的步行马拉松慈善活动捐款。但迈克尔有点不明白什么是步行马拉松。
So he puts in this big bid. And this is an example also of the benefit of the documentary crew element of the show because you can tell at first when Oscar walks into his office and asks him if he'll donate to his nephew's charity, he doesn't want to. If the cameras weren't there, he would probably say no. Right, right. But he can't say no. He wants to look like a good guy.
所以他出了一个大笔捐款。这也是该剧纪录片摄制组元素带来的好处的一个例子，因为你可以看出，起初当奥斯卡走进他的办公室，问他是否愿意为他侄子的慈善事业捐款时，他是拒绝的。如果摄像机不在场，他可能会说不。对，对。但他不能说不。他想看起来像个好人。
He wants to look like a good guy. And so then he goes over the top and he donates $25. And only later is it brought to his attention that it's $25 per mile. Yes, exactly. And that realization happens in a great scene with Jim at the birthday party. And there is just this long pause. I'll tell you what, Steve Carell is better than anyone at letting an emotion wash across his face.
他想让自己看起来像个好人。于是他反应过头了，捐了25美元。直到后来，有人提醒他，那是每英里25美元。是的，没错。这种顿悟发生在生日派对上与吉姆的一场精彩戏份中。然后就是一段长长的沉默。跟你说吧，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在让某种情绪在脸上流露这件事上比任何人都强。
And you watch that emotion of like, oh, crap, like just like, oh, what'd I do? Like go across his face. And I feel like we see this again in Fun Run, right? Because he like signs up to do like so many miles and he doesn't realize what is something about Michael does not understand the concept of a walk-a-thon or anything like that. But no, that is so good. Well, I did, I added it up because in the, in the episode, Michael, once he realizes it's per mile, he asks Oscar like, hey, how strong is your nephew?
看着那种情绪，比如，哦，糟了，就像是，哦，我都干了些什么？从他脸上掠过。我觉得我们在《趣味赛跑》里又看到了这一幕，对吧？因为他报名参加了好多英里，但他根本没意识到——迈克尔就是有某种东西无法理解步行马拉松或类似的概念。不过不，那真的太棒了。好吧，我，我算了一下，因为在，在那一集中，迈克尔一旦意识到那是按英里算钱的，他就问奥斯卡，嘿，你侄子身体有多好？
Like is he in good shape? He did 18 miles. He did 18 miles. So Michael has pledged $450. I did the math. He thinks he's pledged $25, but instead he pledged $450. I also need to go back. I skipped something that I think is really a fun thing.
比如他体能好吗？他走了18英里。他走了18英里。所以迈克尔已经认捐了450美元。我算过账了。他以为自己认捐了25美元，结果却认捐了450美元。我还要回去一下。我漏掉了一点，我觉得那真的是一件很有趣的事。
In the parking lot, there's a scene where Jim and Dwight, what am I going to say? It was Phyllis's car. It was Phyllis's car. Yes. Jim and Dwight are standing next to a car and they are comparing notes about everybody in the office and what they've learned. And they're standing next to a car and it's Phyllis's car. And rain as Dwight keeps kicking the car and Phyllis, she didn't care for it.
在停车场有一个场景，吉姆和德怀特，我要说什么来着？那是菲莉丝的车。那是菲莉丝的车。是的。吉姆和德怀特站在一辆车旁边，他们在对办公室里的每个人以及他们所了解到的情况进行对比。他们站在一辆车旁，那是菲莉丝的车。雷恩饰演的德怀特一直在踢那辆车，而菲莉丝，她其实并不太乐意。
She was very nervous about it. And I guess at some point she went up to rain and said, listen, it's totally fine if you kick my car, but don't kick the car or the hubcap. Just the tire. Just the tire. I, we used to park our cars in that little parking lot. Yeah. And then a lot of our real cars have appeared as cars in the, in the show.
她对此感到非常紧张。我想她在某个时候走到雷恩面前说，听着，你踢我的车完全没问题，但别踢车身或轮毂盖。只能踢轮胎。只能踢轮胎。我，我们以前把车停在那个小停车场里。是的。然后我们的很多真车都作为道具车出现在了，在剧里。
And then they, in seasons later, they had us move our cars. I think maybe they realized there's like liability or something. I mean, so, but in those early days, those were our cars. A very, very big element of this episode is the point where Dwight ends up in a box in the warehouse to spy. And more than any other question, when I put this out to fans for questions, the most questions that we got, the most frequently asked questions were about this box. Right.
后来在之后的几季里，他们让我们把车挪开。我想可能他们意识到这有什么责任险之类的吧。我是说，所以，但在早期，那些都是我们的车。这一集一个非常非常大的元素，就是德怀特最后为了监视而钻进仓库里的一个盒子里。比任何其他问题都多，当我把这个问题发给粉丝们征集提问时，我们收到的最多问题，最常被问到的问题都是关于这个箱子的。对。
How long was rain in the box? How many takes did we do? How many boxes did we use? Right. One of the questions was there's a scene where Pam is on the phone doing a fake phone call and the box kind of tips over and I laugh and run off with a note card. Wait, I have a note card about this. What is it?
雷恩在盒子里待了多久？我们拍了多少条？我们用了多少个箱子？对。其中一个问题是，有一个场景是潘在打电话假装通电话，然后箱子有点倾倒了，我笑了起来，拿着一张便签跑开了。等等，我有一张关于这个的便签。是什么？
I want to, okay, I know you put it out to Twitter, but this is your, your BFF. So I get to, can I, can I ask you first? Okay. One more question. Yes. Did you really break and laugh by the box? I think you did because I know what happens to your shoulders when you really laugh. This was the question.
我想，好吧，我知道你在推特上发了，但这是你的，你的闺蜜。所以我能，我能先问你吗？好吧。还有一个问题。是的。你真的是在箱子旁笑场的吗？我觉得你是，因为我知道当你真正大笑时你的肩膀会有什么反应。这就是问题所在。
This is the question that people want to know. I think I faked it. What? Yeah. I don't think I really broke. I don't want to believe that. I know. I think, because I remember shooting that scene and I remember it was very technical.
这就是大家想知道的问题。我觉得我是装出来的。什么？是的。我觉得我没有真正笑场。我真不想相信那是假的。我知道。我想，因为我记得拍那场戏的时候，我记得技术性很强。
Okay. So it was, I, it was happening over my shoulder, stuff was happening on my shoulder, but there was a way where they wanted me to break at a certain moment. So it was kind of technical. So you had to sort of get out of the way and the box was tipping. Yes, exactly. So I remember shooting at a number of times and I remember thinking to myself, gosh, does this even look real?
好的。所以，它是，它在我肩膀后面发生，我肩膀后面发生了一些事，但他们希望我在某个特定时刻笑场。所以这有点技术性。所以你得稍微让开，然后箱子就倾斜了。是的，没错。所以我记得拍了好几次，我记得当时心里在想，天哪，这看起来甚至真实吗？
Like, do I, it's, it's a really, there are two things that I think are really hard to do when you're acting. One of them is cry. Right. People would expect that. But the other is to laugh convincingly. Yes. You know who has the best fake laugh is Steve Carell.
就像，我，这真的是，我觉得演戏时有两件很难做到的事。其中一件是哭。对。人们会期待这个。但另一件是令人信服地笑。是的。你知道谁的假笑最厉害吗，是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。
Steve Carell can do this fake laugh that is the most honest, genuine laugh. And every time he would do it, I would start to laugh, even though I knew it was a fake laugh. It was so contagious. He, he's the best at it. I find it's easier to cry than to fake laugh myself, myself for acting. Very difficult. It is.
史蒂夫·卡瑞尔能做出那种最真诚、最纯粹的假笑。每次他那样笑，我就会跟着笑起来，尽管我知道那是假笑。太有感染力了。他，他在这方面最厉害。我发现对我自己的演技来说，哭比假笑要容易。非常困难。确实如此。
One reason I think that I didn't really break is because I remember having anxiety over whether or not anyone was going to buy it. Um, Jenna, I have a little something on my note card here. What is it? I have another note card. I wrote, this is the first time we see Daryl. Yes. Yes.
我没真正笑场的一个原因，我想是因为我记得当时很焦虑，担心到底有没有人会买账。嗯，珍娜，我这儿便签上有点小内容。是什么？我还有一张便签。我写着，这是我们第一次看到达瑞尔。是的。是的。
When rain pops out of the box at the end, Daryl is down there. Now, he is not going to have a big scene. We're not going to hear him speak until the next episode, which is basketball. Yes. But that is the first time we see Daryl. So I was very excited. I know. And look, my note card came in handy.
当雷恩最后从箱子里跳出来时，达瑞尔就在下面。现在，他不会有什么大戏份。直到下一集也就是篮球赛之前，我们都不会听到他说话。是的。但那是我们第一次看到达瑞尔。所以我当时很兴奋。我知道。看，我的便签派上用场了。
I love that about her. I love how we plant seeds that grow later. Right. We don't, that is a person who is going to be a major character on the show, but we introduce him just as a guy seeing rain come out of the box. Yeah. That is one of the things, and I know we say it over and over and we will for the life of this podcast, but one of the things I love about what Greg Daniels did is he starts
我太喜欢她这一点了。我喜欢我们如何埋下日后生根发芽的种子。对。我们不会，那是一个以后会成为剧里主要角色的人，但我们介绍他时，他只是一个看到雷恩从箱子中钻出来的普通路人。是的。这是其中一件事，我知道我们说过好多次，而且在我们这个播客的有生之年还会继续说，但格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）所做的事情中我最喜欢的一点是，他从中间切入。
in the middle. He doesn't like spoon feed you information. Just the way they design the show, you play catch up as an audience member. You're just like a day in the life and you're right in the middle. Yes. And I love that. Yes. I love that too.
他不喜欢给你喂饭式地灌输信息。仅仅是他们设计这部剧的方式，作为观众的你就在不停地追赶进度。你就像是在经历平凡的一天，而你正身处其中。是的。我喜欢这样。是的。我也很喜欢。
Okay. Here's a big confession about the box. This is going to blow your mind. What? Rain wasn't in the box most of the time. What? Who was in the box? Phil.
好吧。关于这个箱子，有个重磅坦白。这绝对会颠覆你的三观。什么？雷恩大部分时间都不在箱子里。什么？谁在箱子里？菲尔。
Who's in the box? Phil Shea, our props guy. Yeah. Phil Shea. He is a very tall person. Yeah. Well, so is Rain. And he was in that box all the time.
谁在箱子里？菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea），我们的道具师。是的。菲尔·谢伊。他个子非常高。是的。嗯，雷恩也是。他一直在那个箱子里。
So most of the box acting was done by Phil Shea, of course, except for the end where Rain busts out. And comes in. So in that scene where I'm cracking up, Phil Shea was in the box. Oh my gosh. You know what I think we should do, Angela? Tell me, Jenna. I think we should call Phil Shea and get him to answer all of our questions about the box.
所以大部分箱子里的戏都是菲尔·谢伊完成的，当然，除了最后雷恩冲出来的那部分。然后他进去了。所以在那个我笑喷的场景里，菲尔·谢伊在箱子里。哦，天哪。你知道我觉得我们该做什么吗，安吉拉？告诉我，珍娜。我觉得我们应该打电话给菲尔·谢伊，让他回答我们关于箱子的所有问题。
What was it like in the box? Phil Shea, we are about to blow up your phone. Oh. Phil? Yes. Phil Shea, it's Jenna and Angela. Hi, Phil. Oh, hey guys.
在箱子里是什么感觉？菲尔·谢伊，我们马上就要把你的电话打爆了。哦。菲尔？是的。菲尔·谢伊，我是珍娜和安吉拉。嗨，菲尔。哦，嘿，伙计们。
How are you? Good. How are you? Thank you so much for letting us call and bug you. It's always a pleasure to help out Pam and Angela. Oh my gosh. Phil, thank you so much. It's just so nice to hear your voice.
你好吗？很好。你呢？非常感谢你让我们打电话来打扰你。能帮到潘和安吉拉总是我的荣幸。哦，天哪。菲尔，太谢谢你了。听到你的声音真是太好了。
That's what I was thinking. I was like, gosh, it's so nice to hear your voice. Hey, what an experience we had for nine years, right? Yes. We were the luckiest. We were the luckiest. Well, if you have a second, Phil, can we ask you some questions from the Alliance episode? Absolutely.
我也是这么想的。我当时就在想，天哪，听到你的声音太好了。嘿，我们以前有过九年的美好经历，对吧？是的。我们是最幸运的。我们是最幸运的。如果你有空的话，菲尔，我们可以问你一些关于《联盟》那一集的问题吗？当然可以。
So we opened up questions to the fans and the overwhelmingly, the thing people wanted to know about was the box that Rain gets into in the warehouse. So they wanted to know how long he was in the box, everything about the box. But Phil, I know you were in the box. Rain only got in after all this, the shoeing and the scooching and the sliding and then the tumbling was done. Yeah. Phil, you did all of that in the box.
所以我们向粉丝们征集了问题，压倒性地，大家最想知道的事情就是雷恩钻进仓库里的那个箱子。所以他们想知道他在箱子里待了多久，关于箱子的一切。但是菲尔，我知道你在箱子里。雷恩只有在所有这些——推挤、挪动、滑动还有翻滚结束之后才进去。是的。菲尔，你在箱子里完成了所有这些？
You were the scoocher and the tumbler and all that? I was. Apparently, Mr. Zabornak, our line producer, didn't think we had enough money to hire a stunt guy. So he assigned me to be in the box. And I remember I had to go out and buy my own elbow pads and knee pads. And then I had a loose walkie-talkie in there with me with Liz Ryan, who was the first AP, shouting out all of Brian Gordon, who was our director for that episode's command.
你是那个挪动的、翻滚的还有做这一切的人？我是。显然，我们的制片主任扎博尔纳克先生（Mr. Zabornak）觉得我们没有足够的预算去雇一个特技替身。所以他指派我进箱子里。我记得我还得出去买我自己的护肘和护膝。然后我在里面拿了一个松垮的对讲机，和丽兹·瑞恩（Liz Ryan，第一助理导演）一起，还有布莱恩·戈登（Brian Gordon，我们那一集的导演）在外面大喊大叫着指令。
I remember like it was yesterday. So, Phil, can you take me through it from the beginning? You get a script and it says this character has to be in a box. So what do you do? Because you're in charge of getting the box as the prop master. So where do you start? On that particular prop, I sought out Greg Daniels and I said, do you see Rain sitting down squatting in the box or is he kneeling down on his hands and knees?
我记得就像是在昨天一样。所以，菲尔，你能从头到尾跟我讲讲吗？你拿到剧本，上面写着这个角色必须待在一个箱子里。那你该怎么做？因为作为道具主管，你负责搞定这个箱子。那你从哪里开始呢？针对那个特定的道具，我找到了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，我说，你想象中雷恩是坐在箱子里蹲着，还是跪在地上手脚并用？
And he said kneeling on his hands and knees. And Rain is tall. Rain is tall, right? And so are you, Phil. You're very tall. Yeah. Yeah. Rain is, I think, 6'1 or 6'2.
他说跪在地上手脚并用。雷恩个子很高。雷恩个子很高，对吧？你也是，菲尔。你很高。对。是的。雷恩，我想有6英尺1或6英尺2。
I'm 6'1 if I blow-dry my hair. You do have great hair. Like you guys should know, Phil has an amazing head of hair. He really does. This is true. I leased it. I leased it. It's a Hollywood fake hairdo.
如果我吹干头发的话，我也有6英尺1。你的头发确实很棒。你们大家应该知道，菲尔有一头令人惊叹的浓密头发。他真的有。千真万确。我租来的。我租来的。那是好莱坞的假发型。
But I tracked Rain down and I asked him to get on his hands and knees and I was measuring for this box. Wait, you made Rain get on his hands and knees and then you measured him? You measured him to know how big it was. That was season one. Rain was willing to do anything. Then I went to a couple box cities around Southern California and no one had a box close to that.
但我找到了雷恩，让他手脚并用跪在地上，我开始为这个箱子测量尺寸。等等，你让雷恩手脚并用跪在地上，然后你测量了他？你测量他是为了知道箱子该做多大。那是第一季。雷恩当时什么都愿意做。然后我去了南加州周围的好几家纸箱城，没有人有接近那个尺寸的箱子。
So then I went on to the internet and I looked at box manufacturers in Southern California and I found a company in San Diego named Kent Lansberg and you have to understand as prop people, we have a very short production time and lead time to get all these props. So I called this Kent Lansberg paper company and asked to speak to the manager and in a much more frenetic and hyper voice, I said, look, you got to help me out. I have to have a custom box made. I probably need about 100 of them and they need to be mentioned. Oh my gosh.
于是我上了互联网，在南加州寻找纸箱制造商，我在圣迭戈找到了一家名为肯特·兰斯伯格（Kent Lansberg）的公司，你们必须明白，作为道具人员，我们获取所有这些道具的制作时间和准备周期非常短。所以我打电话给这家肯特·兰斯伯格纸业公司，要求和经理通话，用一种更加狂热和高亢的声音说，听着，你得帮帮我。我必须定制一个箱子。我大概需要100个，而且必须按尺寸来。哦，天哪。
And San Diego, San Diego is like three hours away too. Well, and also that's such a good point. You didn't need one box. You needed a hundred boxes because you didn't know how many takes we were going to do. And Brian Gordon, the director of this episode, ended up being notorious for doing many, many takes. So you were right to cover your bases and get a hundred. Yes.
而且圣迭戈，圣迭戈离得也有三个小时远呢。嗯，而且这也是个很好的观点。你不需要一个箱子。你需要一百个箱子，因为你不知道我们要拍多少条。而这一集的导演布莱恩·戈登，后来以拍摄非常非常多条而闻名。所以你未雨绸缪弄了一百个是绝对正确的。是的。
Right. And we shot that scene in the Dundermiffle and Warehouse and we wanted to have some boxes on the shelves. Oh, right. Just ones that he didn't bust on them. Yeah. Of course. It wasn't a prop box.
没错。我们在邓德米弗林仓库拍的那场戏，我们想在货架上放一些箱子。哦，对的。就是那些他没有砸碎的箱子。是的。当然。那不是道具箱。
It just appeared out of nowhere. So we had to give some legitimacy to where it originated from. Look at all the detail. Look at all the details. I know. So how did you do it? So how did you do it? This guy said he would do it.
它就凭空出现了。所以我们必须为它的出处赋予一些合理性。看看所有的细节。看看所有的细节。我知道。那你到底是怎么做的？所以你是怎么做到的？这家伙说他会做。
No problem. And then how did you get them? Well, I taught him. He said the lead time is usually a month and a half. I said we have four days. Oh, no. I need the boxes in four days and I said it was for a TV show. It says for the office.
没问题。然后你是怎么弄到它们的？好吧，我教了他。他说制作周期通常是一个半月。我说我们只有四天。哦，不。我需要在四天内拿到箱子，我说这是为一个电视剧准备的。上面写着是给《办公室》用的。
It's a remake of the British version. And he probably said, I'm sorry. I'm a huge fan of the British version. I've never heard of your show. Yeah. It's like you guys were listening into the phone call. It's exactly what he said. No, no.
这是英国版的翻拍。他大概会说，我很抱歉。我是英国版的超级粉丝。我从没听说过你们的节目。是的。就好像你们当时在偷听那通电话一样。他就是这么说的。不，不。
He said he would be glad to make an exception for a TV show. So he made it happen. We got the boxes delivered to Culver City, which is where we shot that episode in our first season. And then they put the graphics on the box and we had them back two days before we were filming. So we had it all done and range fit in the box fine. And then it was just about coordinating where the holes would be inserted.
他说他很乐意破例为一部电视剧制作。所以他把这事办成了。我们将箱子运到了卡尔弗城，那是我们第一季拍摄那一集的地方。然后他们在箱子上印了图案，我们在拍摄前两天拿到了它们。所以我们把一切都搞定了，雷恩放进箱子里刚刚好。然后就是协调洞应该开在什么地方。
I mean, I'm inside the box with Dwight's Swiss Army knife and it was a great scene. I mean, I remember we shot that down. I think it was a Friday night we shot that scene, but it was fun. Everybody was laughing. The crew was always laughing on that show. And it was a great scene. And I'm glad the fans love it so much. Oh, Phil, thank you so much.
我是说，我拿着德怀特的瑞士军刀和箱子待在一起，那真是一场很棒的戏。我是说，我记得我们是在那拍的。我想那是周五晚上我们拍的那场戏，但很有趣。每个人都在笑。那部剧的剧组总是笑声不断。那是一场很棒的戏。我很高兴粉丝们那么喜欢它。哦，菲尔，太谢谢你了。
I'm looking at a picture that I can email you that Michael Gallenberg gave me. I'm going to send you a picture as soon as we hang up of me getting ready to tape up the fist box. And I don't know if you have the ability to put the picture on the podcast, but I'm going to take a picture. We can put it on our website maybe. Yeah. Okay.
我正看着一张迈克尔·盖伦伯格（Michael Gallenberg）给我的照片，我可以发邮件给你。我们一挂电话，我就发给你一张我准备用胶带封上第一个箱子的照片。我不知道你有没有能力把照片放到播客上，但我会拍张照片。也许我们可以把它放到我们的网站上。好的。
I'll take a picture and you can see by the expression on my face after about take 50. You were like in a sweat lodge. Oh, Phil, thank you. But Jenna, you were there and you remember the last take when Brian Gordon said one more. I hope you remember this where he had me do all this stuff. And then when I cut myself out of the box, everybody had went and hit. Oh, I came out into the warehouse. So he at least played a practical joke on me at the end to make me laugh.
我会拍张照片，拍到拍了大约50条之后我脸上的表情。你就像在蒸桑拿一样。哦，菲尔，谢谢你。但是珍娜，你在场，你还记得最后一条时布莱恩·戈登说“再来一条”的情景吗？我希望你还记得他让我做所有这些事情的时候。然后当我把自己从箱子里切出来时，所有人都去躲起来了。哦，我来到了仓库。所以他最后至少对我开了一个恶作剧玩笑，让我笑出来。
So that was pretty fun. We did. We left you in the box and we pretended like we were still filming and then you just were there for so long. That is horrible. That is kind of horrible. Why were we so mean? Phil, if I was there, Phil, I would have come up and said, Phil, get out.
所以那挺好玩的。我们确实这么做了。我们把你留在箱子里，假装我们还在拍摄，然后你就一个人在里面待了那么久。太可怕了。这有点可怕。我们怎么能这么坏呢？菲尔，如果我在场的话，菲尔，我会走过去说，菲尔，出来吧。
They left. It was so funny. That was a great scene. Phil, I do. Can I throw two questions at you really quickly before we let you go? Okay. Okay. Yeah.
他们走了。太好笑了。那真是一场精彩的戏。菲尔，我有。在我们放你走之前，我可以快速抛给你两个问题吗？好吧。好吧。是的。
So after getting this box sounds like it was a massive undertaking. Phil, your job is sounding really fun. Like you read an episode and then it's you have to come up with all these weird objects and gags. It sounds fun and stressful, Phil. Like, like how do you get 100 boxes in four days? It's always fun. It's always stressful and it's great to be like a sort of small part of a production
所以弄到这个箱子听起来像是一项浩大的工程。菲尔，你的工作听起来真的很有趣。就像你读了一集剧本，然后你必须想出所有这些奇怪的物体和恶作剧。菲尔，这听起来既有趣又充满压力。就像，你是如何在四天内弄到100个箱子的？总是很有趣。总是压力很大，而且能成为一个制作项目的一小部分感觉很棒。
that resonates with viewers and fans across generations as the office did. So it is fun. It is stressful, but it's a real joy to do it. When everybody laughs and everybody enjoys the prop and it adds a little value to the scripted scene and then we all go home and laugh and have a good day. Yeah. We sure appreciate you and we are going to be calling you a lot at the office, ladies. So thank you.
这个项目能像《办公室》那样引起跨代观众和粉丝的共鸣。所以这很有趣。虽然压力很大，但做这件事真的是一种纯粹的快乐。当所有人都笑了，所有人都喜欢这个道具，并且它为剧本场景增添了一点价值，然后我们都回家大笑，度过美好的一天。是的。我们非常感激你，接下来我们会在办公室经常给你打电话的，女士们。所以谢谢你们。
Thanks for taking the time, Phil. I have vivid memories of all the props we made for the office. So anytime you guys want to call me. Can we? Okay. Anytime. As you were talking, I had like eight questions about different episodes down the road. I did too.
谢谢你抽出时间，菲尔。我对我们为《办公室》制作的所有道具都有鲜活的记忆。所以随时欢迎你们随时给我打电话。真的吗？好的。随时。当你们说话的时候，我脑子里大概蹦出了关于以后不同集数的八个问题。我也是。
We will definitely be calling you back, Phil. Thank you so much. We miss you. Yeah. Let's keep Dunder Mifflin going. I miss you as well. Let's keep Dunder Mifflin relevant for the next 30 years. Okay.
我们绝对会再给你打电话的，菲尔。非常感谢你。我们想念你。是的。让我们把邓德米弗林继续办下去。我也想念你们。让我们在未来30年里继续保持邓德米弗林的活力。好的。
All right, Phil. We'll have a good day. Yeah. Tell everyone we say hi over there. Okay. I will. Thanks, Angela. Bye.
好的，菲尔。祝你有美好的一天。好的。代我们向那边所有人问好。好的，我会的。谢谢你，安吉拉。再见。
Bye. Thank you. Bye. What's next, Jenna? Well, three note cards left. Well, now we need to talk about the cake. Oh, yes. The ice cream, the mint chocolate chip ice cream cake.
再见。谢谢。再见。接下来是什么，珍娜？嗯，还剩三张便签。好吧，现在我们需要聊聊蛋糕。哦，是的。冰淇淋，薄荷巧克力豆冰淇淋蛋糕。
Yes. I got so sick. This is the second most frequently asked question was about the cake and what the cake was like and did we really eat the cake? Oh, we ate that cake, you guys. And guess what? You start filming, we would start filming at 7.30 a.m. Yeah.
是的。我吃得好难受。这是第二个被问得最多的问题，是关于蛋糕的，蛋糕是什么样的，我们真的吃那个蛋糕了吗？哦，我们吃了那个蛋糕，伙计们。而且你们猜怎么着？你开始拍摄，我们早上7:30就要开始拍。是的。
So at 7.30 a.m., you're going to eat ice cream cake? Someone had you a plate of ice cream cake at 7.30 a.m. And you're going to eat it for five hours? All day. All day. And then they're like, let's break for lunch. And you're like, I want to puke. Yeah.
所以早上7:30，你要吃冰淇淋蛋糕？早上7:30有人递给你一盘冰淇淋蛋糕。然后你要吃上五个小时？整整一天。整整一天。然后他们说，我们休息吃午饭吧。然后你就想吐。是的。
Let me say something about prop food. Oh, do it. BJ Novak loves prop food. Mindy Kaling loves prop food. I also kind of like it. I get real excited when I have to snack in a scene. I do not because I know it's going to turn on me. I know.
让我说点关于道具食物的事。哦，说吧。BJ·诺瓦克（BJ Novak）喜欢道具食物。明迪·卡林（Mindy Kaling）喜欢道具食物。我也挺喜欢的。当我在戏里必须吃零食时，我会感到非常兴奋。我才不呢，因为我知道这会折腾我的胃。我知道。
And it's going to turn on me every time. Every time. And I still make the same mistakes. Every time. I would see Ed Helms, Mindy Kaling, you, BJ, be like, ooh, prop food and get so excited. Like, guys, pace yourself. I know. It's going to get gross.
而且每次都会折腾我。每次都这样。但我还是会犯同样的错误。每次都这样。我看到埃德·赫尔姆斯（Ed Helms）、明迪·卡林、你、BJ，就会说，哦，道具食物，然后兴奋得不行。就像，伙计们，放慢节奏。我知道。这会变得很恶心。
We'd have a party in the conference room and they'd have like pigs in a blanket and you just, me and BJ would be over there. I'd be like, guys, slow down. I know. You're going to have to eat that for four hours. I know. Well, this was the first time that I made the mistake and I started wolfing down ice cream cake early.
我们会在会议室里开个派对，他们会有那种迷你热狗（pigs in a blanket），然后我和BJ就会在那边。我会说，伙计们，慢点吃。我知道。你们得连着吃四个小时呢。我知道。好吧，这是我第一次犯错误，我早早就开始狼吞虎咽地吃冰淇淋蛋糕。
And then you have to match that in every shot. So whatever you do in that first shot, you then have to match it. So continuity wise, it all makes sense. And here's the thing. I'm in the background of most of the ice cream eating scenes. What are you thinking? So I was wolfing it down in the background. She didn't have to.
然后你必须在每一个镜头里保持连戏。所以你在第一个镜头里做了什么，你接下来就必须保持一致。这样从连戏的角度来看，一切才说得通。事情是这样的。我在大多数吃冰淇淋场景的背景里。你在想什么？所以我当时在背景里狼吞虎咽。她根本不用吃。
She was in the background. I was in the background and then by the time it was time for my close up, I was so sick. I didn't want to eat the ice cream cake, but then I had to. I'll tell you this. I had a slice and Michael walks up to Phyllis and I. And when he walks up, poor Steve is like wolfing the cake down as he's talking. Oh yeah. He would eat a full piece every take.
她在背景里。我在背景里，然后等到轮到我的特写时，我已经难受得不行了。我不想吃冰淇淋蛋糕，但我不得不吃。我跟你们说这个。我吃了一片，然后迈克尔向菲莉丝和我走过来。当他走过来时，可怜的史蒂夫边说话边像狼一样吞咽着蛋糕。哦，是的。他每一条都会吃掉整整一块。
Oh man. They eventually got a bucket though that he could spit in, which is also disgusting. It's called a spit bucket. It's called a spit bucket. But he would walk up eating the cake and he was talking to Phyllis and Meredith and my character. And I was just going to take one bite as he walked up. And by the end of the five hours of doing the scene, when I would scoop up that one bite, my hand would start to shake because I was anticipating it.
哦，天哪。不过他们最后拿来了一个桶让他可以吐在里面，这也是相当恶心的。这叫吐桶。这叫吐桶。但他会一边吃着蛋糕一边走过来，他当时在和菲莉丝、梅雷迪思还有我的角色说话。我本来打算在他走过来时咬上一口。到拍这个场景的五个小时结束时，当我舀起那一口时，我的手都会开始发抖，因为我在本能地抗拒。
So I was like, hello. Yes, your body was rejecting it. My body was rejecting it. It was like, please don't put that mint chocolate chip ice cream in your mouth one more time ever again for the rest of your life. I can't eat it. I can't eat it. I can't eat it now. I can't eat it now.
所以我当时就像是，你好。是的，你的身体在抗拒它。我的身体在抗拒它。它就像是在说，求求你千万别再把那口薄荷巧克力豆冰淇淋放进嘴里了，这辈子都别再吃了。我吃不下了。我吃不下了。我现在吃不下了。我现在吃不下了。
My daughter loves mint chocolate chip. I don't want it near me. I loved ice cream cake in general. No. And only, it was last year for my son's seventh birthday. I finally ate a piece of ice cream cake again. But that's, it had been like, I'd gone on like a 15 year moratorium. So the final thing I think we should talk about.
我女儿喜欢薄荷巧克力豆。我可不想让它靠近我。我总体上是很喜欢冰淇淋蛋糕的。不。只有，是我儿子七岁生日的那一年。我终于又吃了一块冰淇淋蛋糕。但那是，已经过去像是，我有大约15年没有碰过了。所以我觉得我们应该谈的最后一件事情是。
Oh yeah. Let's go. On that note. The scene with Roy coming into the office and confronting Jim. You guys are so busted. I remember like being over and accounting being like, oh, and also David Denman can be scary when he wants to be intimidating. He can be intimidating. He's such a teddy bear in real life.
哦，是的。我们走吧。顺便说一句。罗伊走进办公室并与吉姆对峙的那场戏。你们俩死定了。我记得当时在会计部那边心想，哦，而且大卫·丹曼（David Denman）当他想表现得具有恐吓性时，真的很吓人。他可以很有威慑力。他在现实生活中其实是个大号泰迪熊。
I know. He's so snugly. When he came in like that, I was like, he's a big guy. He's a big guy. And I think he turns my character on because he's such a man. Like you see that play out later where I'm like, I'm clearly like enamored with Roy. But in that moment, I was like, oh my God, Roy is going to kick Jim's ass. Yeah.
我知道。他太招人喜欢了。当他那样走进来时，我当时想，他个子真大。他真是个大块头。而且我觉得他让我的角色有点春心萌动，因为他太有男人味了。就像你看到后来剧情发展那样，我显然对罗伊非常着迷。但在那一刻，我心想，哦，天哪，罗伊要把吉姆揍一顿了。是的。
Your character, Angela likes a beefy alpha male for sure. She just does. That's true. So I remember this scene. I remember breaking it down. We shot a ton of versions of this scene because we really didn't know how big of a reaction Roy should have. So the first thing I remember was that somehow in the scene when Jim and I are giggling about our accomplishment, we had to find a way to hold hands that there had to be like an organic way and organic way where his arm is around me.
你的角色，安吉拉确实喜欢强壮的阿尔法男。她就是这样。确实如此。所以我记得这场戏。我记得把它拆解开来。我们为这场戏拍摄了大量的版本，因为我们真的不知道罗伊的反应应该有多大。所以我记得的第一件事是，不知怎么的，在吉姆和我为我们的成就咯咯发笑的那场戏中，我们必须找到一种牵手的方式，必须有一种自然的方式，一种他的手臂搂着我的自然方式。
There had to be something because Roy has walked in the door before and seen Jim standing at reception talking to me. So we had to come up with this reason that John would come around the front of the desk. He's so excited. Yeah. He's so excited that he jogs around. So instead of coming up to me with the desk between us, which is what you've seen in the past, this was a big moment. He breaks that barrier. He comes around the desk.
必须有某种方式，因为罗伊之前走进过门口，看到吉姆站在接待处跟我说话。所以我们必须想出一个让约翰走到前台来的理由。他太兴奋了。是的。他兴奋得小跑着过来。所以他不是隔着办公桌走向我，就像你过去看到的那样，这是一个重大时刻。他打破了那个界限。他绕过了办公桌。
He puts his arm on me. We end up kind of holding hands and giggling. And I remember us really struggling to make sure that it looked real and organic and not staged. We didn't want to do something so out of the ordinary that you would be expecting something to happen. Right. And I think we accomplished it. And then when he burst in the door, there were a couple of takes where he pushed Jim up against a wall. Where he got really more physical with Jim.
他把胳膊搭在我身上。我们最终有点手拉着手，咯咯笑着。我记得我们当时真的很挣扎，为了确保它看起来真实自然，而不是摆拍。我们不想做出太离谱的举动，让观众预料到会发生什么。对。我想我们做到了。然后当他冲进门时，有好几条是他把吉姆推到了墙上。他跟吉姆有了更多的肢体冲突。
And so we shot all these different versions so that we could get it just right. Right. And the version they went with is the best. I think if Roy had gotten too physical there, it just would have taken us all out of it because we'd be like, whoa. But I think just how ticked off he was. And then I thought John was brilliant in that moment. He was so believable when he was like, I don't even know how to explain this because he realizes how ridiculous their whole day has been. Yeah.
所以我们拍了所有这些不同的版本，以便把它做到最完美。对。他们最终采用的版本是最好的。我想如果罗伊当时的肢体动作太激烈，就会让我们所有人都跳戏，因为我们会觉得，哇。但我觉得他当时生气的程度刚刚好。然后我觉得约翰那一刻的表现绝了。当他说“我都不知道该怎么解释这个”时，他是那么令人信服，因为他意识到他们这一整天有多荒谬。是的。
And how do you explain what they've been doing? Yeah. And they're so busted though. I know. It is a moment that made me totally cringe. Yeah. And you know that Pam and Roy had words about that. Oh, the car ride home.
你怎么能解释他们一直在做的事呢？是的。不过他们真的被抓了个正着。我知道。这是一个让我感到完全尴尬的时刻。是的。而且你知道潘和罗伊为此吵过架。哦，回家的车程。
And the car. Yes. Yes, car ride home. That was a tough one. My husband and I always talk about that. It will be at a dinner party or something and you see a couple have an awkward exchange. I'll like lean over to my husband and be like, oh, car ride home, car ride home. That's going to be a rough one.
还有车里。是的。是的，回家的车程。那可真够呛。我和我丈夫经常谈论这个。我们在晚宴或者其他什么地方时，看到一对情侣有了一次尴尬的交流。我就会靠向我丈夫说，哦，回家的车程，回家的车程。那会是一段艰难的路程。
So that's it. That's the alliance. Can I say one more thing? I want to say one more thing. This episode has a special place in my family's life. Why? Because while we were shooting this episode, they got me out early so that I could go home for my sister's wedding. My real sister's wedding I had to travel.
就是这样。这就是《联盟》。我能再说一件事吗？我还想再说一件事。这一集在我家人的生活中有着特殊的地位。为什么？因为在我们拍这一集的时候，他们让我提前收工，这样我就可以回家参加我姐姐的婚礼。我亲姐姐的婚礼，我得去外地。
So she got married while we were shooting this episode. And this year she celebrated her 15th wedding anniversary. Aw. And that's sweet. So when I was watching this, I remembered that. That's like a fun full circle life moment too. I know. Well, this is the thing you guys are going to hear a lot as we do this podcast is, you know,
所以她在我拍这一集的时候结婚了。而今年她庆祝了她的结婚15周年纪念日。啊。太甜了。所以当我看着这个时，我想起了那件事。那也是一个有趣且完美闭环的人生时刻。我知道。嗯，这就是你们在听这个播客时会经常听到的，你知道的，
this show spanned 10 years of our lives and so much life happens in those 10 years. And we really do have all these special memories of our own lives mixed in with what was happening on the office. And I feel like it shows because we all became so invested in each other's lives that we are our own misfit family. Like the cast of the, the people that played the characters on the office in real life have a lot of shared life moments and memories. And I think it just makes the show special to me. So when I watch it, I remember things too. Yeah. And it's just so, I love that you shared that.
这部剧跨越了我们生活的10年，这10年里发生了太多的人生。我们真的把所有这些属于我们自己的生活记忆，与《办公室》里发生的事情交织在了一起。我觉得它确实展现出来了，因为我们都对彼此的生活投入了那么多，我们成了彼此的不完美大家庭。就像《办公室》里饰演这些角色的演员们在现实生活中有很多共同的生活时刻和记忆。我觉得这让这部剧对我有种特殊意义。所以当我看着它时，我也会想起很多事。是的。而且这真的，我很高兴你分享了这些。
Yay. Okay. That was the alliance everyone. That's right. Don't judge me for the bobblehead moment. Jenna's already judging me enough. So just, you know, you can rest. I judged you.
耶。好了。大家这就是《联盟》。没错。别因为那个摇头娃娃的时刻评判我。珍娜已经够评判我的了。所以你们只需要，你知道的，放心吧。我评判你了。
And then it was over because then you pointed out that great other fact about your outfit. Thank you very much. Thank you very much. You earned back my respect immediately. I redeem myself. Okay. So you guys, we would love to hear your questions or if we get something wrong. If we miss something, we might miss a few things.
然后就结束了，因为你随后指出了关于你服装的另一个伟大事实。非常感谢。非常感谢。你立刻赢回了我的尊重。我自我救赎了。好吧。所以伙计们，如果你觉得我们有什么地方弄错了，我们很希望能听到你们的问题。如果我们漏掉了什么，我们可能会漏掉一些事情。
For sure. I mean, we get chatty, Jenna. We get a little chatty. And we miss things. We miss things. So write us. Yes. You can contact us at officeladiesatearwolf.com.
肯定的。我是说，我们很能唠，珍娜。我们有点太能唠了。而且我们会漏掉一些事情。我们会漏掉事情。所以给我们写信吧。是的。你可以通过 officeladiesatearwolf.com 联系我们。
If you have questions about an episode, put the episode title in your subject line. Do that for Jenna, please. I like organization. That don't really help us organize your questions. Please do that for Jenna. Or she's going to call me and invent. Or you can even put general Q&A. If it's a general Q&A question.
如果你有关于某一集的问题，请在主题行里写上剧集标题。请为了珍娜这么做，好吗？我喜欢有条理。这真的能帮我们整理你们的问题。请为珍娜这样做吧。否则她会打电话来发火的。或者你甚至可以写“常规问答”。如果这是一个常规的问答问题。
But if it's assigned to an episode, we want to make sure that we flag it for that episode. You know what else you can do? What else, Jenna? You can send us an audio memo. Oh, oh, yes. Do that because then we get to hear your voice and it's kind of fun. Wait, can we play that in the episode? I think we could.
但如果是针对某特定剧集的，我们希望确保为那一集做好标记。你们知道你们还能做什么吗？还能做什么，珍娜？你们可以给我们发送语音备忘录。哦，哦，是的。这样做，因为这样我们就能听到你们的声音，而且这挺有趣的。等等，我们可以在剧集里播放那个吗？我觉得我们可以。
You guys, there's so much fun. There's so much fun. So there's a lot of options. That is officeladiesatearwolf.com. We sound official. We really do. We've got an email. We have an email.
伙计们，太有趣了。这真的太有趣了。所以有很多选择。那就是 officeladiesatearwolf.com。我们听起来很官方。我们真的很官方。我们有电子邮箱了。我们有一个电子邮箱。
I'm excited. Next week is basketball. Basketball. One of my favorites when we became best friends. We became best friends. And basketball. While shooting the basketball episode, we're going to tell you all about it. We'll tell you all about it.
我很兴奋。下周是篮球赛。篮球赛。我们成为好朋友的那一集，这是我最喜欢的集数之一。我们成为了好朋友。还有篮球。在拍摄篮球赛那一集时，我们会把所有的事情都告诉你们。我们会把一切都告诉你们的。
All right. See ya. See ya. Officeladies. Officeladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher, our sound engineer, Sam Keeper. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Remember, you can listen to ad-free versions of Officeladies on Stitcher Premium.
好的。再见。再见。《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。记住，你可以在 Stitcher Premium 上收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本。
For a free month of Stitcher Premium, use code, office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要免费体验一个月的 Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：office。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。